I feel like I look like what your dad looked like in high school
It's bathing suit season so everyone's trying to get hard. It's swimsuit o'clock time to get wet
It's summertime so everyone's worried about their tight bods and tight pussy
F*ck it, you see the title of this video
Here's what girls think about when they work out, its not really what girls think about when they work out
But more what I think about when I work out
Let me know if any of you relate to any of this
Well sh*t. I dressed too sexy. I'm going to be over-sexualized at this gym
Headphones in so we can't hear how people react to the fact that we breathe weird
Did my tampon just fall out?
I'm not new. Let's pick a warm-up song. Instagram Instagram Instagram
we're at the gym. Oh f*ck
This looks like a spaceship. I'm bored. Do it for potatoes
This is a stretch if I sit here long enough. And we're going oh my God look normal. I'm bored
Let's change up the song
Gram Gram Gram Gram we're in a gym
Did my tampon just fall out?
I'm gonna Instagram story me walking on this treadmill
So people think I have a healthy, balanced, cool, productive lifestyle. They got prank so hard. I'm so bored
How do arms work when you're walking?
Just gonna quickly touch my crotch make sure that it is sweat, not urine. We're good
Uhp didn't shave my armpits
So now we walk like this. Someone will think this is yoga
Pilates. Don't fart, don't fart, don't fart. Lots of people cry at the gym. Did my tampon just fall out?
So bored. Where's Sam from Clarissa explains it all? Is holding in farts the same as doing kegels?
I'm exercising. How do we look normal? Smile, smile, smile
We are healthy. Did my tampon just fall out? Wait did I put a tampon in? Oh my God, did I put 2 tampons in?
Oh my God do I have TSS? This has to be TSS. I feel like I'm swallowing blood. Oh no Psych
I'm running lol. Ansel Elgort is 23 very cool so is exercising. We've been doing it the whole time
Oh my God Im gonna sh*t my pants. No you're not going to sh*t your pants. You're fine.
We just gotta get back on this treadmill
We did it. Don't fart, don't fart, don't fart. That's a new smell. Here come the endorphins
I can do anything. Oh f*ck sh*t slow. I broke all of my toes. England is my city. Well, that's a new crevice
Well there you go. That's what girls think about when they work out. Do you feel educated?
I feel tired. If you liked this video, give it a thumbs up and if you want me to do more videos like this
Let me know any suggestions you have in the comments down below
and subscribe to this Youtube channel. Click the subscribe button
Click that little bell to get notified because I make videos Monday, Wednesday, and Friday
Sometimes and sometimes I don't
I don't know
It's speedo season, lets dip it in
Its stretch-your-underwear season again time to get hot
It's time for swim trunks Badonkadonks and getting funked
Sorry that they're all winners